how are you Michael Richard uncle well
Happy Thanksgiving yeah right back to
you sir right back at you so I was
talking about this the other day with
with Brockman over here and I did it
with Dan Patrick today too is that when
the Rams and the Titans made that trade
we called you up you thought it would
have to be for Wentz because you liked
went off now we see what golf looks like
this year where do you stand on that
subject after seeing these two kids fall
out 2007 I mean I'm where I am and have
been - the first time I watched carson
wentz pro football and and it was
cemented when i spend time with him rich
Jim you know you you and I were
fortunate because we get to meet a lot
of these guys in the NFL spend time with
them and when you sit down with a peyton
manning or a Matt Ryan or a Drew Brees
or a Russell Wilson you walk away with a
certain feeling and I remember being in
Fargo North Dakota at when's his pro day
and after I sat down with him I walked
away go minutes it's Tom Brady that's
Matt Ryan that's ruffle well as who this
kid is
so you know I he was number one on my
entire board that year not just a
quarterback what the Jared golf thing is
a revelation and confirmation to me how
much coaching matters and and I think
we're seeing it a lot rich with how the
young quarterbacks are being treated in
the NFL today how so walk me through
that
Mike all right let's take deshaun Watson
okay yep
he was number one on my board last year
as far as quarterbacks but my comment
was I didn't keep you ready to play year
one and I couldn't have been more wrong
about that
and I had his game I think was I had a
gain I had two of his games this year
you know he lit up New England and I'm
watching them play against England I'm
watching all the game film I saw them
play live twice and I give Bill O'Brien
a ton of credit because what are you
doing rich is in the old days and I mean
just a couple years ago coaches took
these huge play books and said to the
rookie first-round quarterback you go
kid
you know go learn it and we'll play when
you're ready or will play or before
you're ready even though you haven't
learned
and now what their donors are sitting
down with these talented young kids and
they're saying okay what makes you
comfortable and I'm watching the child
Watson run around with his own Reid
quarterback draw bootlegs play actions a
bunch of stuff he did at Clemson and the
kid was just electrifying it was so much
fun to watch and while he's learning how
to be a pocket quarterback in the NFL
he's experiencing success because Bill
O'Brien has allowed him to dictate what
he's comfortable with and I'm seeing
that of Marcus Mariota I feel a similar
way with him Jared Goff this year he
gets a coach that he's really
comfortable with who's got it
who's got an ability to sit down with
them and say what makes you come from
what you do a cow you know one of the
looks you're comfortable with and that's
a long answer rich and I apologize no I
really believe that Kenneth L coaching
staffs have kind of stepped back and
said okay we have to play to the
strengths of what these talented kids
bring to the NFL and I give the coaches
credit for that well mike Mayock here in
the Honda inside a report you know it's
a copycat league don't you think there
are gonna be other teams that want to go
get themselves as Sean McVeigh for their
young quarterbacks that that may be one
of the reasons why John Fox needs to
look over his shoulder in Chicago at
Mitchell drew Biscay having the reins
now thrown in his direction
Mike well I don't think it has to be a
young guy I think the smartest thing
that Sean McBay did was hire an old
defensive coordinator and a veteran
staff I really believe that but I do
believe it has to be and it doesn't have
to be the head coach but that helps I
mean bill O'Brien's an older guy and
Bill O'Brien completely changed who he
was when you had Christian Hackenberg
Penn State when he inherited the Shaun
Watson and I think that's what you've
got to be willing to do and I don't
think it's just John McVay I think the
entire league I mean look in Tennessee
you know Marcus Mariota with the
play-action his own reads when he's
healthy boy he's explosive and he's
becoming
better and better pocket quarterback so
I'm really positive and upbeat about a
lot of these young quarterbacks rich
especially since we're gonna lose a
class of guys over the next few years
you know like the Eli Manning's and Drew
Brees rippers Roethlisberger Brady you
know we're gonna lose some special guys
and I'm excited about this young crop a
quarterback well I mean before we get to
that young crop that's even coming out
of college
let's hit Mariota because I do have him
coming up in about a half an hour on
this show the word regression has been
used for him what do you see when you've
been evaluating Mariota this year for a
team that's right there in the mix for
the division a wild card or or anything
else for the Titans Mike well I think
they've been handcuffed well he's been
handcuffed a little bit with with
injuries and you know when when you're
trying to come back and play and you're
not 100% as a quarterback and a big part
of your game are your feet and ability
to escape an ability ability to run zone
read and on 3rd and 1 or fourth and goal
so I think he lost part of his upside
coming back from some nicked up kind of
injuries but the flip side to that is it
forced them to be in the pocket a little
bit more than and I don't I don't see a
regression I just think we look at
Jameis Winston you know he's hurt right
now he was struggling a little bit you
know it's not going to be call clear
sailing for Carson Wentz and Jared Goff
I mean they're gonna get spanked here
and there so I'm really bullish on
Mariota I I think he's got a chance to
be special ok mike Mayock here in the
Rich Eisen show let's get to Baker
Mayfield how do you think the NFL talent
community and evaluation community is
viewing what just happened in Kansas
that's caused him to have the captaincy
stripped from him this week and play
play a shortened game it's at all this
coming weekend Mike no I think they see
some maturity but but here's what I
would tell you in the big picture rich
you would much rather you know how I put
it he that was an immature act and and
certainly demanded that his coaching
staff
to plan him and I am happy they did but
he's a competitive kid and I think NFL
community would rather see a competitive
quarterback who's immature and will grow
out of that rather than a player that's
been arrested and all you know there's
been physical abuse or there's been
armed robbery or you know all the stuff
that we have to deal with it draft I
when you when you kind of slot that in
you want the guy to be a leader
absolutely
okay what did he do well in a
competitive situation on game day
not a not off the field on the field he
was a jerk and reacted to a group of
Kansas kids that were jerks for not
shaking hands pregame and I hate it and
I'm happy he's disciplined but let's see
if he learns from the lesson and moves
on the end of the day you know he's a
really competitive kid and he did
something he regrets I'm sure so that'll
brought a battle definitely be brought
up to him with the grease board in the
rooms in Indianapolis come February
thousand times but I don't think it's in
any way I think he'll handle it fine
and as long as there isn't any repeat
issues I don't think it's gonna cost
them anything a draft on well I don't
know how deep you are in your evaluation
again you're calling games NFL games
during the season so um do you think
he's got a first-round grade right now I
think I think there were mixed emotions
on this kid and I spent about four hours
watching his film two weeks ago can I be
honest I went into it a little bit
skeptical and I had only really seen him
on television and I'm thinking okay you
know either he sees a sawed-off 600 or
511 or whatever he really is and you
know he's got a little bit of Genie
magic to him but I came away after four
hours of tape going oh I better watch
myself this kid's got a legitimate arm
bigger arm than I expected and what I
really like which is when he escaped the
pocket he escaped to throw not to run
and even though he can run and I believe
he's competitive I believe he's tough I
think he's mostly accurate
I hate that conference from a tape
watching perspective quarterbacks row to
open windows all day long and watching
him and Baker him in the Mason Rudolph
Oklahoma Oklahoma State was watching
like watching seven-on-seven
nobody covers anybody so unbelievable
how do you handicap as we're here on
Thanksgiving weekend Rosen and Arnold
you just played each other this past
weekend Mike that was a fun TV watch I'm
looking forward to getting the tape in I
would tell you this Rosen from a pure
thrower perspective as gifted as anybody
as I've seen in several years I mean he
he just can wake up at 4:00 in the
morning and rip it and there's no doubt
about that I think people want a day go
on the kid more what kind of kid really
is he really and that's part of the
process especially at that position
Donald I like I love his competitiveness
I love him being out of the box I love
the average 20-some points a game in
high school basketball you can see it in
his football game you can see him
leading the fast-break and distributing
the ball having said that I'd love to
see you have another year in college
just because he's been so inconsistent
this year and I'm intrigued by Lamar
Jackson and I'm intrigued by Josh Allen
for different reasons and rich you know
I mean there's a kid at Auburn that
could come out there's a kid at
Mississippi State and the senior class
this year you know we already talked
about Mayfield and Rudolph you know
there's guys like Luke Falk and Riley
Ferguson and I threw in the tape because
he might get a senior role invited a kid
from Sam Houston State in Jeremiah
Briscoe I'd never heard of and he rips
it big arm so it's early in my process
but I'm kind of leaning towards being
really excited about this group
quarterbacks depending on who actually
declares with you underclassmen sure and
last one for you Mike is say qualm
barkley just jumps off the screen right
at me and when I look at him I see
perhaps a more talented Devonta Freeman
Mike and and him in that San Francisco
Kyle Shanahan offense would just
holy cow that would be potent I'm
wondering how you evaluate him last one
for you here and the on it
Honda inside a report is we're getting
set for a Thanksgiving weekend
well the Heisman Trophy really went to
the best player in the country he would
probably win it hands down but it
doesn't and he's as good a running back
as I've evaluated in a long time his
Iowa Cape is the most special running
back paid by two years and you know Zeke
Zeke Elliott went at number four and I
think this kids got more up side both on
and off the field indeed it so I think
again I'm nowhere near done all my take
for this year but so far he's the best
player I've seen okay
Mike you have a great Thanksgiving where
you gonna spend it where you can spend
it imma I'm gonna have a quick family
thing at noon tomorrow and get my car
and drive to Washington because I've got
the Redskins Giants car and I look
forward to that call for you Mike okie
Mike keep my ear gate as Mike urban
would say out for that one Oh Mike we
did it in the meeting on Saturday and
we're like we got to put this on
television that all you got to do he
tells it did you did you miss this one
Brockman he says all you gotta do is
tell I tell 300-pound guys three and
three you're 300 pounds that guy's 300
pounds stay in front of him for three
seconds and you can make 300 million
dollars and the best part of it was
Marshalls face in the bathroom it was
the same face he had in the meeting Mike
[Laughter]
save me you Mike best of it all the may
ox and we'll chat down a lot always miss
chat with you we got to do it more
thanks rich that's a mike Mayock at mike
Mayock on twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience